Rob's World!
Hey guys this is Rob's World and welcome
to my tutorial for the..
This is a cool Ninja Star that Jeremy
Shafer designed! Thank you very much for
your comments on my last video for the
paper wallet
I got a lot of comments there asking to
make a triple ninja star
since I showed one at the end, but check out what happened when I threw it!
Nice, it's done!
Now to test it out.
Man! It's just not flying well
*Phone dialing/ringing*
Hello? Hey Jeremy it's Rob..did you
figure out that Triple Ninja Star
design yet?
Hey Rob, yeah I got it right here hold
on
I'll show it to you.. look out your front door. Wait, what?!
Oww! Did you get it? Yeah man this is pretty awesome!
It flies pretty far too! Hey you should definitely teach it on your channel
And is pretty sharp too! I'm sure they're
going to like it! The triple ninja star
or ninja tri-star
is a type of modular Origami, meaning
we're going to interlock
each of these individual units together in
order to get the ninja star
if you're going to use Origami paper,
make sure that the white side is facing
up like this when you start. I'm using
three colored sheets
of letter size paper. To make it into a
square I take the top edge and fold it
down to the left side
and then I tear it along this edge here.
Now that we have a fold going this way
we're going to take the upper left
corner and fold it down to the lower
right corner
line up the edges..
and then make a crease along the edge
now you'll see we have an X in the paper
once again just fold it on the diagonal
and we're going to take this lower edge
here
and we're going to take both these
layers and fold them
up to this edge, so you can just kinda
hold it like this
and line this edge up at the top
once everything's lined up then you can
make a crease. Now
you'll see we have a big triangle here
on the left and a
right triangle over here on the right
we're going to take this
edge of the smaller triangle and we're
going to fold it up
so that it meets this edge which we just
folded in right here
so you can just take it like this it's
probably easier to set it down
but just so you could see, fold it up
like that
line up the edges
and then crease it
Now, we're going to flip the model
around
and I'm going to take a this edge here
that we just made and I'm gonna fold
it up to the top edge right here
So take it
fold it up
and you could hold it right here,
make sure the edges all lined up
and then you can make that crease
If you're using printer, it's going to get thick here, so just be sure to hold it
it nice and tight
when your folding it. Once again we're
going to take
this bottom edge and fold it up to the
top
here it gets a little bit thick so be
sure to hold it snug right here
with your right hand. Now you can fold it up
you'll see this corner right here
will actually join with this corner
that's right here
Just fold it
join those corners up, pinch it..
and make crease along the bottom
It's a little thick, but just crease it as best
you can
Now, you can actually
unfold this corner by grabbing this
corner here
and just pull it out just like that
and this corner which is tucked in, you
could just unfold this as well
So your paper should look something like
this:
now we're going to fold this
edge right here along this
crease which we made, so you just want to fold
on that crease right here
just like that
we're going to take this corner and
we're going to fold it in
by taking this edge and aligning it
with this edge if the paper so it's easier
if you can hold it like this
Then you can easily take that edge
hold this down with your left hand so it's
nice and flush with the paper
and make sure
that edge lines up with the other edge
then you can make that crease there. Okay so
now that this corners folded in
we're going to take this edge in the
paper here
and we're going to join it with this
edges as well
So, what you do.. fold that in like that
and you could just pinch it like this
now as you'll see on the paper
there actually is a crease that goes
diagonally like this
however we need to make a new crease
right next to it
where this corner meets the paper we
need to make a mark
Right there. Now if you want to be really
precise and you're using
eight-and-a-half by 11 paper
the mark that you're going to make is
exactly five millimeters (half a
centimeter)
to the left on the bottom up this crease
right there
if you follow this little crease all the
way to the top
right at the top here is where we're
going to make the second mark
now I'm going to draw a line so that you
could see it a little easier
so as you'll see it's just a little bit
off
from the main mark and the reason that
we're doing this
is because this angle that we're going
to make has to be
a 120 degrees now we're going to take
this bottom edge and we're going to fold
it up
so that it lies directly on that line we
just drew
put your finger nail right here in the
corner and pull up
now you can lay that edge directly on
that line
all the way to the top just like that
and make crease along the bottom here
So you should have something that looks
just like this
Now, you can unfold this
and just flatten it out. We're going
to take
this part of the paper and we're going
to fold directly on
this crease here right where my finger
is when you take this paper
and we're going to fold up like this
And we're going to take the rest of this paper here
and we're going to wrap it around just like
this
Pull it nice and tight!
it's not gonna quite line up at the
bottom here but that's okay
now you'll see we have a little flap
here
and we have a pocket right in here you
want to take this flap
and you're going to fold it down so that
the fold lines up with the top of the
pocket just like that
now you can open the pocket and you can
tuck this flap in
as far as it can go
just like that. There you go!
that's how to make the modular
3-Point Tri-Star Unit!
once you've made three then we can interlock them
if you take a look at the unit you'll
notice there's a pocket here on the front
where we tucked that flap
there's a pocket on the back on the same
side
it's a little bit thinner and there's also
a point here
we're going to flip all three units
upside down so that thinner pocket
is on the top
then we could take two of the units
we're going to take this point
that doesn't have the pocket and
we're going to join it with the thin
pocket here
that doesn't have that little flap, so
you're gonna take two pieces like this
take the point and put it
right in the pocket just like that
and just use your thumb to kind of push
it down.. now we're going to take the
other one
and just remember we're holding it so
that the pocket
where the flap was tucked in is on the back
again
we're going to take this point and we're
going to put it
into the thin pocket right here on this
piece now
and slide at all the way in
we're going to take this third piece
that we just tucked in
and we're going to take this part with
the pockets
and we're going to put it underneath the
tip
of the first one the blue one, so take
it
and slide that underneath like that
you'll see
this is the point of the blue piece
we're gonna bend it and put it in this
little sleeve or pocket
of the yellow piece, which is the third
piece, so all you need to do is to round
this off a little bit
put that inside
all the way in and use your thumb to
kind of push it
Then you can set it down
flatten everything out and there you go!
You have the Triple Ninja Star..now as
you'll notice
is a little bit concave meaning these
points are actually bent
a little bit to the left like that when
you see these tabs
on the right. If you didn't make the
guide Mark correctly or you folded it at
the existing crease
this is what would happen. Now I'll show you how to throw it. Alright so I found that
the best way to
to throw it is to have these little tabs
on the back
facing to the right, so you can hold it
just like this
in your right hand. If you're lefty,
you can throw it like this
Hold it like this and throw it
overhand and let it spin out of your hand
If you want to try to throw it sideways you
can do that as well
Let's see if I can hit my portrait
Ahh, it came apart!
thank you guys very much for watching
this video, be sure to subscribe by
clicking this little button down here
Thank you very much again to Jeremy for
showing me this awesome design. Let me
know what you guys thought of this video
leave me a comment below and also let me
know what you wanna see next
and we'll see you next time!                                (Subtitles by Rob's World)